Nina's home because we're in China so I
married someone who is the size of an 11
year old but it's true 10 Oh Mike it's
even worse guys my hair is my stop what
are you guys going to do in the future
fish in the meadow sorry I like it
what's a real shark okay neem is here
we're gonna go find her no I'm gonna go
find her who's gonna find her Nina hog
Nina we love her we missed you Nina woke
up at what time this morning you only
have an hour to an hour and half sleep
yeah well she had an hour and a half
sleep last night that's not a lot Nina
always sees the food and wants to take
it home and eat it
where we going next
Figment is it one of your favorite rides
imagination is leamons keeping us
organized places on Louie saxophone we
love Nina what is that let's see yeah
it's a nice fan like this would you wear
that all day scarred alright it's
lunchtime Nina wanted to come to the
winnie the pooh fish and chips how is it
guys oh yeah me that's good let's see
how was the lunch guys great good
fishing shows this Felicia
it was fun you know it you know what
Nemeth day
just left off you fell asleep she has
that lean it with some flowers she's
very cute we wanted to cool off a little
bit so we came to starbucks Nina and I
are getting a venti caramel frappuccinos
and Louise going healthy cup of sugar
strawberry smoothie he's going to join
healthy sheer I hate in this Mickey hat
get a little heat stroke so I took my
hat back from Hayden and told me he's
gotta buy one and Louie is going for 12
the kids want me to get a hat too
hi Becca
what do you think this is what an angry
strong super looks like
and this is what they look like with
their other emotions they all good
things that's the point Lina's cute we
love her it's a very special place for
us oh cuz we met you we met here in
Mexico last year we were hearing it I
figure Oh who's this hello hmm what's
your name huh imagine meeting you in a
place like this here we go we're here on
the stairs hey what's a girl like you
doing here in Mexico Lina's home cuz
we're in China hello
all right it didn't fit very good kind
of good stylist about is a nice shirt
yeah yeah medium and large but they'd
have a small maybe I should gain some
way to me no I don't think that's a good
idea you know we should have just looked
in the kids that was like Nicki Minaj
they had children's clothing maybe we
should look there next time this is Nina
and this is her niece Stephanie and
they're the same height yeah so I
married someone who is the size of an 11
year old but that's true 10 Oh Mike it's
even worse here we are in Germany it's
you again now in Italy huh time for some
funnel cakes how about thank you
hot
goes ok yeah at the last stop of the day
pets track build their own car and we'll
see
you guys ready all right yeah that's
track second jeffree star in my car this
is hayden and Nina's card oh yeah this
is skyler louise car
crazy
okay we're leaving Monday at epcot yeah
okay guys what's the day better or
yesterday better yesterday and today
yesterday and today okay you want to
wait goodbye wave goodbye see you
tomorrow welcome everybody held a
three-hour healthy factor has gone up a
little bit since Nina has shown up she
brought the magic bullet to make
smoothies here we go you want to get on
the Pirates no you're gonna stay out
here okay let's go how was it it was
scary next up Peter Pan's light beam is
looking cute today
guys my hair is my stop when it's
lunchtime kids are getting chicken
nuggets and chocolate milk and grapes
yummy I made you this Evan Anina having
lobster rolls with chips yogurt and
Louise having feltham healthy salad and
all right he gritted gotta make the wife
happy when you go on vacation ya ready
what are we going on Big Thunder
Mountain
what did we miss it was have fun yeah
get this is the wife about Carl R which
is very special I'm saying nice things
she's just really just on her cell phone
hate is our new driver because he wants
to push the little kids around
oh wait who's this little kid he was a
little kid sitting in this trailer
we weren't able to start the day with
Starbucks like Nina like to because we
had the Russian we're late
but we made in here ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to introduce you to my wife
zina it's time for some Frappuccino okay
Stephanie what are we doing next we're
going to me Tinker Bell
alright we're all set to watch some
marching band and then the big parade
the kids are sitting in the corner
eating their ice cream they're excited
trying to take them on a rail home all
right did we guys that we have a good
day what was our favorite part /
Mountain Flashman full ride I'm getting
stuck on for I did tweet Disney we got
stuck on for rides technical
difficulties let's see what happens
we'll see if we get a response from
Disney on Twitter tomorrow we are off to
Hollywood studios and if the kids don't
sleep in and take forever to eat will do
Jedi training any morning the force is
with us we'll see